mouammar kadhafi était un homme très
brillant homme politique intérieure et
ça je crois qu'on n'en parle pas souvent
qu'ils savaient très bien faire
fonctionner ce monde très complexe
qu'est le monde libyen qui ne renvoient
pas seulement à l'opposition cyrénaïque
tripolitaine si vous voulez mais à une
fragmentation qui est la fragmentation
des sociétés traditionnelles et le
colonel kadhafi savait très bien trouver
les transactions que ces systèmes appel
si bien que le beau système qui a si
brièvement marché que l'on a mis en
place après s'est trouvé en quelque
sorte miné par le fait qu'il n'était pas
forcément adaptées à la structure
sociale
on fait comme si on pouvait plaques et
des systèmes économiques des systèmes
politiques sur des sociétés quelle
qu'elle soit et ses sociétés très
diverse réagissent très différemment à
ce type de système qui n'opèrent pas
tous de là toujours de la même manière
selon les sociétés auxquelles on les
applique
[Musique]